I recognize his name I think we played a
decent amount on leechas
she might also be a streamer too have we
played on trust.com
and once
okay London time
Joe Bava London time
usually H5 is included but
it shouldn't make a huge difference here
yeah they do it with Queen D2 is the
castle is also to unpin the Knight so I
can play 95.
yeah it's a very common trade
so now F3 is an idea
and Bishop 5 can be met with G4
there's another idea to play King B1 and
then eventually take on D5
there's some tactics against Black's
Queen
wow
so I think I'll start with King B1 huh
it feels very close to having cool
tactics
okay I think what I'd like to do is play
E4
and then the threat will be Knight takes
D5 Queen deck Z2 Knight takes E7
checkmate
there's also Knight B5 is an idea
tactics are potentially really crazy
here
this still work this still might work
wait a minute
I don't think I've ever seen this
specific idea before Knight takes D5
three different pieces can take it
take
wow
I'm assuming this works
so Queen takes its mate
if Pawn or Knight take I take and then
I'm still mating
and this is just mate
okay
that was a cool tactic
oh man
yeah like usually this this idea happens
when
The Queen Is Not defended and usually
the king is like Castle kingside
but I've never seen it where it allows
for Bishop A6 checkmates
because yeah there's so many cases where
as black you just assume that white has
to take back
but this was a an in-between checkmate
there's a concept of in-between move
in between Checkmate can be kind of
powerful oh it's not winning though King
B7
ah the engine kills all the fun
okay it's pretty close to winning
White's much much better
but black could have fought on
Knight takes D5 isn't even the best move
what's Knight A4
what is Knight A4
wow Knight A4 that's a cool idea look at
this move 984.
so it uses the same idea
like when black plays B6 in this
position
the thought process should be
how do I remove the queen so I can get
Bishop A6 checkmates
and I played the first move that I I
considered which okay was effective
enough
but I guess I could have considered
other night moves because any night move
attempts to remove the queen Knight E4
as well
but Knight A4 it's cool
let me turn off engine
and the idea is after Queen takes A4
white to move
there's a nasty move here
wait but does it work
okay I I was thinking Queen before a lot
of people in child are saying Queen B4
one person says Queen A5 which loses a
queen and then you don't have Bishop A6
checkmates
um
I actually don't think Queen B4 is the
right move
because there's C5
and then after takes takes we've removed
the queen but this isn't Checkmate
anymore
so I'm pretty sure
assuming what the engine wants is is B3
first
Queen A5 we take and then we mate and if
Queen A3
only then do we play Queen B4
and then C5 doesn't defend the queen
because Bishops don't move like this
so let's check with the engine
B3 only winning move
and then black has to give give the
queen somehow
it's crazy how many people would play
Queen B4 and then be worse with whites